out to holland a wide open look but he  can't hit it middleton with the  offensive rebound  underneath for the dunk and it's a  two-point game great great  90 seconds to go giannis feverishly  calling for the ball the holiday  pritchard  a chance to get the bucks their first  lead of the game  holiday they got numbers if they hurry  middleton gives it up holiday paul  williams backside block kept alive  though  [Applause]  what a sequence what a sequence  okay they want the switch they want that  switch right there there it is  tatum drives  gives it up williams  with the block as williams went for the  dunk  challenge that  yep he's gonna challenge it and they'll  go to the replay monitor to see if it  was last touched by boston ruled on the  court but it was last touched by  milwaukee we just saw an explosion there